قدرت اعمل الدراجات لاشخاص كبار بالعمر بس
عندهم مثلا نحكي ما عندهم توازن او بخافوا
من التوازن بلحظه بغض النظر عن العمر اللي
هو واصل له وانه ركب دراجه هوائيه وقدر
يمشي فيها انت يعني كنت موجود معه بلحظه
فرح يعني كدرجات او كتصنيع لذيذ بالاردن
هي مش بس انا بسمع بسكليت انا بسمع فرحه
يعني بحقق امنيه لشخص انه نفسه يكون اشي
هيك موجود
[موسيقى]
انا خالد عبد الكريم العمر عمري 45 سنه
انا من دوله احتياجات الخاصه قبل ثلاث
اطفال بحب اني المغامره وبحب اغامره
الحياه بكل شيء وعندي فكره دي بالاردن من
الدراجات الهوائيه في 2016 تقريبا نزلت
مع اصحاب ايلي على البحر الميت
واضطريت اركب الدراجه الهوائيه الاستاندر
فكوني بلبس جهاز للحركه بيجري فكان
الموضوع صعب جدا علي
يعني حبيت اني اكون في اشي افضل لهيك لاني
اضطريت اربط اجري بسلك وعلى البداله عشان
ما تفلت فكان في بالي انه ليش ما يكون
مثلا انه انا اغير مكان البداله او انه
يتغير محور الحركه كامل بالنسبه للدراجه
الهوائيه الخاصه بدوله احتياجات او بشكل
عام كدراجه غريبه فمن هذيك اللحظه بلشت
افكر ليش ما انا اصنع هاي الدراجه
والحمد لله بعد 8 شهور قدرت اطلع اول
بروتوتايب او اول عينه اللي ناسبت الظرف
او الوضع الصحي اللي انا فيه فكان احلى
شعور انه لما مشت اول مره على الشارع يعني
كانت تجربه جدا حلوه انه انت قدرت تصنع
دراجه لك بتناسبك
[تصفيق]
يعني قدرت اجيب عدد قدرت اطور على الفكره
قدرت اعمل دراجات لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
كل طفل او كل شخص حسب احتياجه دراجات كبار
العمر تعجال فالحمد لله يعني قد ما بقدر
بحاول اطور على نفسي واطور على المشروع
وابحث عن فرص ثانيه اني اقدر احصل دعم
اللي اطور اكثر على فكره
دراجه تتصنع حسب الطلب بمواصفات الشخص طول
ايديه عرض اكتافه اذا عنده اي احتياج خاص
اذا كان طبي او اذا كان تصرد القامه كل
هاي بتنقد بعين الاعتبار اني انا ببعث
فورم الزبون بعبي كافه تفاصيله وبناء عليه
بتم تصنيع الدراجه له بالمقابل هو ما راح
يلاقي ستاندر او اشي بالسوق بقدر يخدموا
مثل الدراجه المصنعه بالضبط للمواصفات
اللي هو طالبها
فهاي الدراجات كوطن عربي قليل ومش موجوده
[موسيقى]
لاي انسان ما عنده اي تحدي خاص هي صحه
ورياضه وبتساعد بالتنسيق دوره الدمويه
بتخلي فما بالك في شخص من ذوي احتياجات
خاصه بس الحمد لله رب العالمين كان دعمي
من زوجتي من اصدقائي من اهلي انه فكرتك
كثير حلوه لا توقف يعني انت لما بتحكي انه
انا بلشت من 2016 بحلم انا الان موجود
كعلامه تجاريه كاسم دي بالاردن جوديب يعني
صارت اشي ملموس ومعروف انه عندك حلم لا
توقف انه افرد جناحك حلق بحلمك راح توصل
على انك تكون قادر انه بدك تعمل دراجه او
انه صناعه الدراجه لشخص او لطفل هو
محتاجها هاي بحد ذاتها تحدي انك تسمع فرحه
لغيرك مثلا قدرت اعمل الدراجات لاشخاص
كبار بالعمر بس عندهم مثلا نحكي ما عندهم
توازن او بخافوا من التوازن فهاي لحالها
بتخليك تضلك تفكر كيف تقدر تطور وتساعد
غيرك لتخليه يتمكن انه يكون موجوده بهيك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني ان شاء الله رب العالمين في بامريكا
سبعه
بالمانيا في بايطاليا وراح يكون من الاردن
راح يكون بالشرق الاوسط برضو في بلده
لكاستنباي سيكل وان شاء الله ان شاء الله
اذا الامور مش هتلاقي قدام فكره ناصر ابني
عمره سبع سنين انه نعمل جوذي باور اللي هي
دراجات 250 فمادون الكاستا من اولد سكول
فان شاء الله هاي راح تكون ان شاء الله من
ضمن المحقق لجودي
[موسيقى]